Unbekannte haben per Mailware unbemerkt 80 Millionen US-Dollar aus der Zentralbank von Bangladesch gestohlen. Denn digital hatte die Bug nicht viel aufzubieten, um Einbrüche zu verhindern. Auch vollständig nachvollziehen ließ sich die Attacke nicht. So fanden Gutachter in der Bug 10 Dollar Gebrauch-Twitches und monierten das Fehlen jeglicher Firewalls. Ein größerer Schaden wurde nur verhindert, weil sich die Ganoven bei einem Empfänger vertippten und Kreditinstitut TUTU so bei der Zentralbank nachfragen mussten. Diese stornierte dann die Überweisungen, die sie sonst um eine Milliarde US-Dollar erleichtert hätten. Ob man die verbliebenen Millionen nun in ein vernünftiges Sicherheitskonzept investiert, ist nicht bekannt. Der Browser-Hersteller Opera bietet erstmalig ab Werk einen gebündelten, kostenlosen VPN-Dienst an. Im aktuellen Developer-Bild lässt sich der Browser so konfigurieren, dass Webseiten den Anwender als Nutzer aus Deutschland, den USA oder Kanada wahrnehmen. Die Daten werden nach Angaben des Unternehmens im VPN-Tunnel verschlüsselt. Der Dienst wird durch den VPN-Anbieter SurfEasy realisiert, den Opera im letzten Jahr übernommen hat. Auch wenn das Angebot Fehlversprechen klingt, empfehlen wir, AGBs lesen und kritisch bleiben. Wenn wie Opera den VPN-Dienst gegenfinanzieren will, scheint noch nicht klar. Die kanadische Polizei verfügt offenbar seit dem Jahr 2010 über die Fähigkeit, Nachrichten des Blackberry Messengers zu entschlüsseln. Dazu verwendeten sie den globalen Schlüssel, den eigentlich nur Blackberry besitzen sollte. Es ist daher anzunehmen, dass das Unternehmen den Schlüssel selber an die Behörden übergeben hat. Eigentlich sollten zentrale Schlüsseldankmethoden wie Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung jedoch gar nicht notwendig sein. Entsprechend schlecht schneidet der Blackberry Messenger auf dem Secure Messaging Scoreboard der Electronic Frontier Foundation ab. Dieses gibt eine Übersicht der Sicherheit von Messagern unter verschiedenen Sicherheitsaspekten. Den Link findet ihr in den Show Notes. Sicherheitsforscher von Checkpoint haben das sogenannte Nuclear Exploit Kit analysiert, mit dem Kriminelle vor allem den Verschlüsseln des Trojaner Loki verbreiten. Es bemüht dabei gleich mehrere Sicherheitslücken in VB und JavaScript für Internet Explorer sowie Flash und Microsoft Silverlight. Weitreichende Freiheiten bei der Gestaltung von Werbekampagnen sorgen immer wieder dafür, dass auch vermeintlich vertrauenswürdige Websites durch eingebundene Werbung zur Infektionsquelle werden können. Damit eure nicht dazu gehören, empfehlen sich wie immer regelmäßige Updates, einen guten Adblocker und einen Browser mit Click-to-Run-Funktion oder eine Mülltonne für untote Browser-Erweiterungen wie Silverlight, Java und Flash.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück zum Chaos Radio 222 aus der Marienstraße 11, wo es heute um Orte geht wie den Ort in der Marienstraße 11. Das ist nämlich die Heimat des Chaos Computer Club Berlins. Und es geht heute um Hackspaces oder Hackerspaces. Und wir haben schon in den ersten Stunden, in der ersten Stunde gelernt, was das überhaupt ist und was man braucht, um das zu gründen und haben auch etwas über dieses Design Pattern Handbook oder wie auch immer das genau hieß. Ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Hackerspace Design Patterns.
Hackerspace Design Patterns gelernt. Ich begrüße nochmal herzlich die Gäste. Gizmo ist das. Hallo und guten Abend. Ich verwechsel die beiden immer, sie sehen auch so ähnlich aus. Aber der eine hat eine Mütze und der mit der Mütze ist Joel. Und Pylon.
Hallo.
Und ihr wolltet noch kurz etwas zu den Design Patterns sagen.
Ja, das Spannende ist halt einfach bei den Design Patterns gewesen. Wir hatten halt den Vortrag dann in Köln gemacht, eine kleine Runde mit zehn US-Hackern halt zusammen. Und im Anschluss kam dann Brie Pettis auf mich zu, wie gerade schon angesprochen, bei dem Make-Magazin damals dabei gewesen, hat er geschrieben und fragte mich so, kann ich die Folien haben? Ich sagte, ja klar, hier hast du einen USB-Stick, kurz mal übergeben. Was ich nicht wusste, ist, dass er zwei Minuten später auf das Blog vom Make-Magazin gestellt hatte. Das Ding dann irgendwie einmal komplett weltweit rumgegangen ist, irgendwie zigtausend Leute erreicht hatte und plötzlich poppten dann irgendwie weltweit so die ganzen Hackerspaces auf. Es wurde in mehrere Sprachen übersetzt, es hat aber ungefähr fünf bis sechs Jahre gedauert, bis man in Deutsch übersetzt wurde. Aber es gab irgendwie ganz schnell danach dann irgendwie so spanische und japanische Übersetzungen, was ich total lustig fand. Und was auch noch interessant war, dass viele von den Pattern so eins zu eins übernommen wurden. Ein Beispiel wäre so ein Pattern mit reingebracht, so das Mate-Pattern. Also du brauchst in einem Hackspace Mate. Was man hier so auf dem Tisch stehen sieht, so damit man auch nicht einschläft, ist auch besser als diese komischen andere zuckerhaltige Getränke mit Koffein. Also hab Mate da. Da gab's dann auf einmal plötzlich so ganze Vertriebskanäle, die dann irgendwie versucht haben, Mate in alle Welt zu importieren quasi. Es ist grauenhaft, wo du heutzutage überall Mate findest. Du kannst wirklich in fast jeden Space reinkommen, egal wo du hingehst, ob du jetzt irgendwie in USA bist, in der Türkei bist oder sonst wo auch immer. Du findest Mate dort vor Ort.
Dann hast du ja auch klar geworden, was ihr damit angerichtet habt.
Eine weltweite Bewegung.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich so. Es gibt dieses Verzeichnis hackerspaces.org, das ist ein Wiki und da werden halt die ganzen Digger gesammelt, da findet man auch die Design-Patterns. Und 2007 war halt so ein Explosionsjahr, da ist halt irgendwie von ein paar Spaces, die da verzeichnet werden, ist es dann ganz schnell in eine dreistellige und dann vierstellige Zahl irgendwie von Spaces gekommen.
Also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, passt auf, was ihr aufschreibt, es könnte möglicherweise ein weltweiter Trend daraus werden.
Ja, tatsächlich bin ich auch ein bisschen stolz. Also dieses Wort hackerspaces, wo ich immer noch nicht genau weiß, von wem das eigentlich geprägt ist.
Publikum, weiß das jemand?
War halt einfach da so 2006 rum und ja, ein paar Jahre später, also ich glaube vor ein paar Jahren, hat dann halt auch das Oxford English Dictionary beschlossen, das dann halt aufzunehmen.
Ach wirklich?
Und das passiert einem ja auch nicht so oft im Leben, dass halt so ein Wort, wo man die Bewegung halt mit initiiert hat, dass das dann halt irgendwie in so einem Wetterbuch auftaucht.
Meine Herren, liebes Internet, falls du weißt, wo das hackerspaces herkommt, auch gerne sagen, bei Twitter, at chaosradio oder...
Am Anfang auch so. Es klingt auf jeden Fall sehr germanisch. Hackerspace und so, das klingt wie so eine Kompositionsbildung, die halt so Deutschen gefällt. Deswegen glaube ich, dass es halt schon so aus unseren Kreisen kommt, um das zu beschreiben, was wir halt machen. Manchen Leuten, ja gerade wenn man dann hackerspace sagt, dann klingt das im Deutschen so, als ob da halt nur männliche Hacker sind und die Hackerinnen irgendwie draußen bleiben. Deswegen benutzen manche das Wort hackspaces. Aber eigentlich ist es egal. Also benutzt einfach das Wort, was euch lieber ist und ob ihr hackspace oder hackerspace sagt. In den USA gibt es auch ein Female-only-hackerspace. Macht einfach, was ihr für richtig haltet. Mich stört das nicht.
Ich wollte hier aber genau zu dem Punkt zurückkommen, den wir vor der Musik hatten. Und zwar, dass es dieses Leute treffen zusammen, gründen zusammen etwas und brauchen dann naja ein Konzept dafür, wie man Entscheidungen trifft. Und ich bin darauf gekommen, weil ich mal ganz fasziniert dabei war, wie ein Hausprojekt angefangen wurde. Und da wurde als allererstes, also bevor alles andere probiert wurde, wurde sozusagen, wurde ich zusammengesetzt und tatsächlich aufgeschrieben, wie die Entscheidungsfindung in der Gruppe so auszusehen hat. Das fand ich sehr, sehr, sehr spannend. Jetzt ist es ja so, die hackspaces, das habe ich heute gelernt, sind eher so Dinge, die relativ spontan passieren und dann auch aus sich raus wachsen. Deswegen würde mich tatsächlich interessieren, wie sich das auch, vielleicht habt ihr auch Anekdoten sozusagen über den Lauf der Zeit entwickelt hat. Und Gizmo, ich würde gerne bei dir anfangen, weil du bist ja der Schuldige sozusagen, also der, der sich bei euch in der Raumfahrtagentur sozusagen hat hinstellen lassen, um eine Firma zu gründen. Bist du denn auch der Chef?
Nee, nicht wirklich. Wie gesagt, das organisatorische Vehicle hier ist die Firma, die eben dann auch den Mietvertrag hält, die Stromrechnung bezahlt und eine Versicherung haben wir noch für ein paar Kleinigkeiten, das war's. Das wird getragen komplett von den Beiträgen. Das ist ungefähr so das, was zu null laufen muss, sonst wird es irgendwann schwierig. Das ist auch der Fall über die Jahre, sind jetzt acht Jahre damit relativ gut rumgegangen. Wir haben zwei Umzüge hinter uns gebracht. Zur Entscheidung gehören natürlich schon auch noch ein paar mehr, vor allem die Leute, die diese Werkstatt nutzen und den Raum nutzen. In der Organisation von der Raumfahrtagentur ist es so, dass wir da jetzt nicht dedizierte Bereiche haben für Leute, die dort ihren Arbeitsplatz haben oder ihren Schreibtischspiel, so ein Co-Working-Space, sondern es gibt nur dedizierte Werkstattbereiche. Also die unterschiedlichen Maschinen, die unterschiedlichen Disziplinen, Techniken haben jeweils einen definierten Bereich, einen Teil des Raums zwischen eben 3D-Druck, Tonstudio, Textilverarbeitung, Elektrotechnik, solche Sachen. Und da bilden sich zwangsläufig Krüppchen drum rum, Nutzer, Kernuser, also Leute, die regelmäßig im Space sind, die mit einem Thema sehr vertraut sind, womöglich selber noch eine Maschine mitgebracht haben, die also da so ein bisschen den Hut aufhaben in diesem einzelnen Bereich. Und dann Leute außen rum, die das halt regelmäßig nutzen oder auch seltener, je nachdem. Und so ist es also, was mich betrifft, so den Chef zu spielen, eigentlich die initiale Claim-Geschichte zu handeln. Also wo welche Bereiche landen. Wenn es darum geht, einen neuen Raum, wie gesagt, zwei Umzüge waren es bisher, zu besiedeln, gilt. Danach halte ich mich da auch schwer zurück. Beziehungsweise danach ist es Gegenstand von den Leuten, die es betreiben und die diese Bereiche managen.
Aber geht das sozusagen immer konfliktfrei? Oder gibt es auch so Dinge, wo ja schon...
Gut, wie gesagt, das waren ja schon ein paar, ungefähr zehn Jahre Hintergrund. Die Leute verstehen sich ganz gut. Und gerade wenn es ums Fachliche geht, eben einen solchen Werkstattbereich, dann trifft man sich doch irgendwo in der Mitte und in dem Führung, dass es dann halt auch in Ordnung ist. Also sei das jetzt auch so ein bisschen eine Policy zum Aufräumen oder zum Bestandhalten. Das müssen dann die Leute im Unterricht klären. Sie machen einzeln jeder Fachbereich. Ich wollte gerade sagen, da gibt es auch so ein paar Unterschiede. Dass, ja, Östern-Tagesgeschehen ist klar, da ist natürlich auch immer wieder was los. Große Kernfragen nicht. Und auch der Investitionsbereich ist bei uns immer so ein bisschen außen vor. Das machen die Projekte, die Leute selber.
Herr Graf-Bürger, ich hätte dich nicht fragen sollen, wie trefft Entscheidungen, sondern wer putzt eigentlich? Aber gut. Joel, wie ist das bei dir? Entscheidungsstrukturen in Hackspaces. Wie macht man es am besten? Ich meine, klar, ihr habt in eure Design-Pattern geschrieben, irgendwie Dienstagsplanung. Aber funktioniert das denn immer und funktioniert das so reibungsfrei? Also wenn ihr mir jetzt, also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, wenn ihr mir jetzt alles erzählt, es gibt keine Probleme und das Plenum ist ein wunderbarer Ort und es regnet Blumen, dann muss ich sagen, dann habe ich die Menschheit bis jetzt falsch eingeschätzt oder ihr erzählt mir Märchen.
Nein, das ist kein Buckle, das ist kein Feature. Es gibt keinen Hackerspace ohne Hackerspace Drama. Und der Goldstandard für Hackerspace Drama ist für mich Noise Bridge in San Francisco. Also die performen einfach das am besten, am unterhaltsamsten auf ihrer Mailing-Liste, um ein Beispiel zu nennen, das liegt halt in einem eher alternativen Teil von San Francisco. Und irgendwann war da so eine Gruppe, die gesagt hat, hier, ihr habt doch so einen offenen Raum und ihr seid doch völlig frei in euren Gedanken und jeder kann da was machen und wer macht, hat Recht und so weiter. Ich würde diesen Raum gerne nutzen. Und dann wurde gesagt, ja klar, mach ruhig. Der nächste, der dann in den Raum kam, fand den Hackerspace verwandelt in einen Sektentempel. Räucherstäbchen waren da, der Guru stand vorne, eine Gruppe von Meditierenden saß im Raum und hörte gespannt zu. Und irgendwann wurde dann das auch auf der Mailingliste gesagt, also ja, jeder kann sich hier selber verwirklichen und wer macht, hat Recht. Aber das geht jetzt doch ein bisschen weit weg von unseren Kernkompetenzen. Vielleicht sollten...
Das ist so eine Art Sielenlöten.
Genau. Also kein Hackerspace ohne Hackerspace Drama. Und meistens sind es halt auch wirklich diese Themen wie wer macht sauber, wer putzt die Klos? Im anderen Hackerspace, dem mir sie am Herzen liegt, das MetaLab in Wien. Da waren sie immer sehr stolz darauf, dass sie alles im Konsens machen und nie Abstimmungen machen müssen. Und dieses hässliche mit der Demokratie, das die größte Minderheit, die kleinen Minderheiten alle unterdrückt und so. Bis sie dann halt, ja das ist eine Geschichte, die ist schon ein bisschen älter. Mittlerweile hat sich das in Europa auch anders entwickelt. Aber damals haben die Leute noch geraucht. Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht, da gab es Raucher. Und da kam dann der Winter und einige Leute haben im Hackerspace geraucht. Und andere fanden das unmöglich. Und da gab es das erste Mal eine Abstimmung im Meta-Lab, wie die jetzt mit dem Raucherproblem vorzugehen ist. Man hat das dann so gelöst, dass man ein kleines Kabuff eingerichtet hat, das sogenannte Gesundheitskammerl. Und im Gesundheitskammerl durfte geraucht werden. Mittlerweile ist der ganze Hackerspace aber auch rauchfrei. Also Kultur ist irgendwie weitergegangen. Aber ja, kein Hackerspace ohne Hackerspace-Drama gehört dazu.
Okay, Pülon, hast du da auch noch eine Anekdote vielleicht beizusteuern?
Bekannt sind auch Schreitherapien bei Plenums. Das kommt auch immer wieder mal vor, dass dann doch durchaus die Gespräche etwas ausarten und ein bisschen lauter werden. Ich fand es früher anstrengend. Mittlerweile sehe ich das durchaus als Kulturprogramm an. Man kann da auch sich mal zurücklehnen, einfach mal fünf Minuten warten, bis alle Meinungen ausgetauscht wurden in etwas größerer Lautstärke. Dann geht das auch schon wieder vorbei, dann kann man wieder in Ruhe weiterreden.
Aber sowohl man macht das mit Schreiterpätherapie als auch, dass wer macht, hat recht. Das klingt aber schon noch, als die Leute, die viel Energie haben, bestimmen das Vorgehen im Hackerspace.
Ja, wenn wir jetzt weniger lustig darüber reden, es kann dazu führen, dass so ein Hackerspace umkippt, dass die Stimmung ganz schlecht wird und dass alles ein bisschen autoritärer wird. Das ist schlecht. Also wenn da irgendwie das Ganze innerlich vergammelt und eine schlechte Kultur drin ist, dann kann so ein Hackerspace auch umkippen.
Also warum ich mir die Frage stelle, ist, dass ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass es zum Problem werden kann im Sinne von, das wirkt ja, so wie es erzählt hat am Anfang, immer so relativ fluffig. Also man trifft sich so, man denkt so, hey, wir sind uns irgendwie sympathisch und wir gründen jetzt einfach mal dieses Ding und dann geht das vielleicht auch ganz lange im Konsens, dass man alles macht. Aber irgendwann erreicht das ja so eine kritische Schwelle, wo man merkt, jetzt geht es halt nicht mehr, jetzt können wir es sozusagen nicht einfach so machen, sondern jetzt müssen wir tatsächlich auch reflektieren und mal sozusagen darüber reden, wie wir vielleicht auch reden. Und ist das so eine Schwelle, woran so ein Hackerspace dann auch irgendwie zerbrechen oder scheitern kann? Wenn das nicht funktioniert?
Kann passieren. Also unsere Erfahrung sagt so aus den letzten 15, 20 Jahren, man hat immer so Höhen und Tiefen eines Spaces, man fließt ja in eine Sinuskurve oder so ein bisschen ansteigende Sinuskurve, die halt immer so ein bisschen mehr wird. Das heißt, man hat dann irgendwie mal so einen Hoch, vielleicht nach einem Camp, was halt alle vier Jahre stattfindet, dann ist es auf einmal super toll und der Space läuft super. Alle sind glücklich und es wird dann vorangearbeitet. Und irgendwann ist das für manche Leute vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel. Dann zertrennt sich so ein bisschen die Gruppe, schreit sich vielleicht mal zwischendurch auch an oder auch nicht. Und dann kann es passieren, dass die Gruppe auch mal zerbricht oder manche Leute in einen anderen Space gehen. Ich meine, es gibt Städte, wo mehrere Spaces sind. Dann besucht man einen anderen Space, geht mal ein bisschen Oper hacken und so was in der Richtung und kommt vielleicht später wieder. Aber man kann sagen, so eine Sinus-Kurve von fast schon vier Jahren, die man halt so dazwischen hat, so alle vier Jahre ist alles super. Und dann gibt es vielleicht immer zwei Jahre, wo es mal ein bisschen nicht so toll ist.
Das Camp ist an allem schuld.
Durchaus.
Cat, ich würde das von dich natürlich jetzt auch gerne fragen. Die eine Sache ist ja genau so sagen, man kann es halt sagen, wenn man jetzt so ein Ding gründet und das auch gleich in größer angeht, was ihr jetzt vorhat. Spielt das auch eine Rolle? Also habt ihr das auch vorher besprochen oder ergibt sich das auch so?
Also wir haben keine Entscheidungsstrukturen festgelegt, aber viele von uns haben so einen Aktivisten-Background irgendwie und auch teilweise in gemeinsamen Gruppen, wo wir auch so Pläne haben und Basisdemokratie, die schon sehr lange sehr gut funktioniert. Und würden das denke ich auch auf diesen Space anwenden. Und da wird auch nicht so oft rumgeschrieben.
Aber was heißt das konkret?
Dass Entscheidungen einfach im Plenum getroffen werden, aber nicht mit Mehrheiten, sondern so weit das Möglichkeit ist, jeder seine Meinung preisgeben kann und dann gemeinsam eine Lösung findet.
Das klingt alles so schön.
Es kann auch funktionieren.
Also es ist auch nur fast unrealistisch, weil die Leute, die so ein Hackerspace bevölkern, die sind halt ganz stark intrinsisch motiviert. Die wollen halt einen eigenen Raum haben. Die haben Wissensdurst und die brennen innerlich dafür, dass dieser Raum gefüllt wird. Da ist ganz selten die Motivation, ich mach jetzt alles kaputt. Trotz aller Schreittherapie und so findet man doch dann wieder zueinander.
Meine Vermutung war tatsächlich auch nicht gewesen, dass jemand denkt, ich mach jetzt alles kaputt, sondern dass es zwei Leute geben, die eine ganz genaue oder zwei Lager gibt, oder drei oder vier, die eine ganz genaue Vorstellung davon haben, was der richtige Weg TM ist, um sozusagen den Hackerspace zu betreiben. Aber ihr habt vorhin vieles, das war ein Halbsatz, und da würde ich gerne nochmal genauer hingucken, die Tür. Ich kann mir vorstellen, es gibt tatsächlich bei Hackerspaces viele praktische Probleme, die man irgendwie klären muss. Zum Beispiel, wie dick ist eigentlich die Internetanbindung, die man in so einem Hackerspace braucht. Reicht eine landesübliche 100-VDSL-Leitung, falls man die Verfügung hat, oder braucht man mehr? Da wird der Fuel schüttelt mit dem Kopf, sagt man, eine Zahl einfach nur?
Ja, immer das Maximum, was geht. Also Glasfaser direkt in den Hackerspace.
Okay, und dann ist es tatsächlich die Frage der Tür. Das ist ja eigentlich ganz spannend. Weil man wird ja wahrscheinlich keinen da haben, der auf die Tür aufpasst. Das heißt, man muss entscheiden, wer darf denn da ein- und ausgehen.
Genau, da gibt es unterschiedliche Modelle, also auch in den meisten Spaces, die ich so kenne, ist das so, dass irgendwie den Schlüsselmember zu sein, das hat irgendwie dann was mit Mitgliedschaft in dem Hackerspace zu tun. Und ist dann oft auch an bestimmte Sachen gebunden, dass man dann halt irgendwie regelmäßig auf dem Plenum erscheint oder in dem Entscheidungsgremium, was es da gibt. Das ist dann meistens noch so eine nicht so thematisierte Hierarchie, die dir nachher reingegeben wird. Das sind die Mitglieder und das sind die Mitglieder mit Schlüssel. Es gibt allerdings auch ganz andere. Also NoiseBridge, die ich eben als Goldstandard in Drama erwähnt habe. Die sind halt aber auch in anderen Sachen richtig goldig und lieb. Also Mitch Altman von NoiseBridge fährt durch die Welt und verteilt Schlüssel für den NoiseBridge Hackerspace. Ich hab dann auch einen bekommen. Du hast bestimmt auch einen.
Ich hab einen aber nie benutzt, weil ich noch nie da war.
Genau, also einfach, wenn ihm Leute sympathisch sind, drückt er einem den Schlüssel in die Hand. Das ist halt eine maximal offene Türpolitik, weil das halt auch immer alles gerne technisch gelöst wird. Wollte ich gerade fragen. Gibt's halt irgendwie ganz unterschiedliche Lösungen. Fast jeder Hackerspace fängt dann erst mal mit einem Türprojekt an. Also wir müssen erstmal an den Türstatus nach außen kommunizieren. Irgendwie ein Bot, der das auf Twitter macht oder auf der Webseite wird ein grünes Lämpchen angeschaltet oder sowas. Das ist so ein Standardprojekt, was irgendwie jeder Hackerspace am Anfang machen soll. Mittlerweile gibt es, weil wir ja alle Standards lieben, halt auch einen Hackerspace-Türstatus-Standard. Da gibt es halt eine API-Spezifikation, wie man halt in Hackerspaces auf der Welt den jeweiligen Status dann abfragen kann.
Aber warte, meine Theorie wäre, es gibt zwar diese API, aber es hat noch kein Hackerspace geschafft, die umzusetzen.
Nee, das haben erstaunlich viele Hackerspaces.
Ich möchte mal, können wir bitte kurz aufzeigen, wer ist denn alles aus dem Marienstraße 11, also den Ort, an dem wir uns befinden hier? Aha, hier geht nur eine Hand hoch. Ach, da hinten noch ein paar. Gibt es hier ein Türprojekt? Weiß das jemand?
Nee, nicht wirklich. Das hier ist ganz klassisch. Hier gibt es Schlüssel tatsächlich. Und du musst schon dazugehören und dass sie entsprechende Vertrauen auch aufgebaut haben in der Halberg-Gruppe, um dir einen Schlüssel ergattern zu dürfen.
Das Vertrauen, wie macht man das? Weil Schlüsselmämmer viele ja schon sagen, so eine Hierarchie gibt es ja auch im Designpattern. Oder gibt es da auch sozusagen...
Das war nicht damals im Designpattern vorgesehen. Wir haben ganz viel übersehen, was wir dann halt irgendwie...
Aber gibt es in euren Erlebnissen jetzt sozusagen, was muss ein... Also eine Raumfahrt Agentur ist wahrscheinlich zu sagen, wenn man da an sich den Werkstatt, sozusagen wenn der Werkstatt nachher darf, dann geht das?
Ganz klassisch, es gibt auch eine Schließanlage, Schlüsselsystem, also entsprechend, genau, also Schlüsselmember, keine elektronische Anzeige über den Besatzungsstatus.
Aber was muss man machen, um Schlüsselmember zu werden? Also wie...
Selbes Spiel, es ist eine Vertrauensfrage natürlich, Zugang zu den Räumen zu gewähren und dementsprechend sind das bekannte Leute, die schon länger da sind, das wachsen Leute mit in der Raumfahrt Agentur dazu. Also die freuen jetzt nicht unbedingt direkt aus dem CCC-Umfeld, die schon bekannt waren. Das ist dann natürlich so eine Übergangsphase und man lernt sich erstmal kennen und dann tauchen die regelmäßiger auf, man kommt da so ein bisschen weiter rein. Und dann ist das dann auch irgendwann geklärt. Beziehungsweise dann ist dann auch die Schlüsselfrage.
Kat, habt ihr da schon irgendwie Pläne? Wollt ihr das... Also gibt's schon einen Plan?
Also wir haben in unseren Finanzplan 20 Schlüssel reingeschrieben. Wir haben irgendwie ein Budgetverschlüssel, aber wir haben da noch keinen Plan. Ich glaube, es kommt auch ein bisschen drauf an, wo der Space ist, wenn einer von uns direkt nebenan wohnt und die Tür aufmacht. Also keine Ahnung, müssen wir mal sehen.
Aber ihr habt auch nicht geplant, dass es irgendwie Öffnungszeiten gibt oder so was?
Also soll halt möglichst offen sein, die meiste Zeit einfach.
Wie ist es bei euch zu sagen, wie wird man Schlüsselmember? Wenn jetzt nicht gerade jemand von der Neuspitch kommt und sagt, hier, geiler Typ, du hast einen Schlüssel.
Naja, wenn du jetzt nicht selbst den Space mit gegründet hast und dann quasi zu der Ursuppe dazu gehörst, dann hilft es schon, einfach mal vorbei zu kommen an einem offenen Tag. Zum Beispiel Dienstag, wenn er offen ist. Dich einfach einzubringen, vorzustellen, ins Gespräch zu kommen. Öfters wiederzukommen, einfach mal regelmäßig da zu sein. Ob es jetzt einmal im Monat ist oder wöchentlich. Ein bisschen was Vertrauen aufzubauen. Vielleicht auch mal einen Vortrag reinzubringen oder einen Workshop. Dann irgendwann so, du bist ja so oft hier und du hast ja schon mal mitgekauft, Toilette zu putzen.
Möchtest du Schlüssel haben? Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das ist der wichtige Punkt. Ihr müsst einmal die Toilette mitgeputzt haben. Gut, was man sonst noch so in Hackerspace machen kann, also ab von denen das alleine runterwerkelt, das klären wir gleich. Jetzt noch eine kleine Musik von Ryan Harley, Growing Pain. Growing Pains von Ryan Harley hier im Chaosradio 222, wo wir noch eine halbe Stunde haben, um über Hackspaces zu reden. Und wir wissen jetzt eigentlich schon alles, was man braucht, um sie zu gründen. Also wichtig ist, dass man einen Verein hat, dass man Geld hat, dass man eine Tür mit Schlüsseln hat und dass man das Klo putzt. Das ist jetzt so ganz grob zusammengefasst die letzten 90 Minuten.
Das ist aber schon sehr grob.
Ja, naja, man kann ja, man soll ja auch sozusagen den Podcast nochmal hören können, wenn er dann raus ist. Die sind auch mittlerweile schon Gäste abhanden gekommen. Ach ja, guck mal, da kommt der Pylon nochmal zurück. Wo sind eigentlich die Ketten? Verschwunden, explodiert.
Wir überzeugen uns von dem Ort der vorbildlichen Sauberkeit und Ordnung in diesen Räumen.
Wir möchten das nicht weiter ausfinden und ins Detail sagen. Jetzt ist es ja so, der Hackspace, über den wir jetzt geredet haben, ist ja ein Ort, in dem sie Individuen finden und dort sozusagen ihr individuelles Zeug machen. Jetzt sind wir alle Individuen, aber wenn Menschen zusammenkommen, kann es vielleicht noch ein bisschen weitergehen. Gibt es das tatsächlich, also gibt es außerdem Plenum noch andere Dinge, die man zusammen macht? Also jetzt, okay, man ist vielleicht zu dritt an der Werkbahn, weil man ein gemeinsames Projekt hat oder sowas. Bei Cat klang es vorhin schon an, also, nee andersrum, du hast ja erzählt, das hat sich daraus entwickelt. Ihr habt ganz viele Angebote für Frauen gemacht, die total überlaufen sind. Wie ist jetzt dieser Hackspace gedacht? Ist da auch dieses Gemeinschaftsding, soll das da mit drin vorkommen?
Ja absolut, also alles was da entsteht, entsteht ja aus einer Gemeinschaft heraus und es geht ja auch viel darum, irgendwie mehr Frauen in diese Community mit rein zu holen und das funktioniert unter anderem dadurch, dass man auch zum Beispiel Einsteiger-Workshops anbietet. Ja, dann sind überhaupt erstmal die Leute irgendwie da abgeholt, wo sie sind. Also das machen wir und ganz viele von den Workshops, die wir jetzt anbieten, die entstehen einfach auch aus der Community heraus, dass die Frauen sagen irgendwie so, ja, ich hab Bock, einen Hardware-Workshop anzubieten, ich bring euch Löten bei oder so, das passiert da so.
Aber ist das sozusagen so, jemand kommt und sagt, ich mach das einfach und dann versammeln sie sich um einen Tisch, der gerade da ist, irgendwie vier Leute oder wird das wirklich so geplant? Also am 23.08. um 17 Uhr Workshop, Löten, Platzzahl, 30 Leute.
Genau, das wird schon so geplant. Also wir haben ja jetzt noch keinen Space, wo man sich irgendwie versammeln kann, außer Donnerstags. Donnerstags wollen wir auch irgendwie ein Kulturprogramm anbieten. Das wird aber alles mal vorher angekündigt. Und bei den Workshops ist es in der Regel so, man sagt, ich bock das zu machen irgendwie. Dann müssen wir gucken, wo wir einen Raum herkriegen. Also wir haben ja wie gesagt viele Organisationen, die uns unterstützen, deren Büros wir nutzen können oder Labs. Und dann kündigen wir das im Kanäler an oder auf Twitter, mit einem Twitter-Account. Genau, und dann wenn es eine begrenzte Platzanzahl gibt, das meistens leider so ist, weil man die Leute ja betreuen muss, je nachdem, was man da macht, dann müssen die sich anmelden.
Wie ist das in der Raumfahrt Agentur? Das ist ja sozusagen ein eher geschlossener Verein. Du hast erzählt, ihr habt verschiedene in dem Space Spaces, wo das einzelne Werkzeug sozusagen ist, worum sich Gruppenbildung, aber habt ihr auch Dinge, die ihr alle zusammen macht oder ist das wirklich eher so eine Art zusammengestecktes Modul, wo sich kleine Gruppen haben?
Ja, das ist schon sehr zusammengesteckt. Gemeinschaftswerkstatt, die Räume sind physisch die Klammer, wo wir da operieren. Und wir sind in dem Fall sehr verteilt, unterschiedlichste Projekte, unterschiedlichste Leute. Da sind dann die für sich selbst zuständig, einen öffentlichen Auftritt zu machen, das zu kommunizieren. Wir laden dann auch gerne mal ein, lange Jahre BioLab mit im Haus gehabt von einer Dame, die dort DIY-Bio-Technik betrieben hat. Da finden dann natürlich auch mal Veranstaltungen oder Talks statt, solche Sachen. Aber das ist dann schon immer sehr konzentriert auf die Projekte, die dort halt ansässig sind. Elektronenrad, wenn ich jetzt hier mit meinen Elektrofahrrädern ein Thema habe und so, dann ist klar, Raumfahrtagentur ist die Raum, die Möglichkeit in der Werkstatt, wo sowas passiert, aber einen großen Auftritt und eine Präsentation, wie es beim Hard of Code sein wird, ist das gar nicht da an der Stelle.
Okay, also während man sich so zu sagen Hard of Code zum Beispiel, als das eine große Theater vorstellen kann, seid ihr eher das Kino mit verschiedenen Sälen? Pylon & Joel, wie ist es bei euch sozusagen, also Dinge, die Hackerspaces für die Gemeinschaft bringen? Was kann da noch passieren?
Das ist ganz unterschiedlich. In Köln läuft immer noch regelmäßig ein an einem Jahr mehrwöchiges Projekt für Jugendliche, das ist so genannte U23, also für Leute unter 23, dass dort dann eine Projektreihe ist, die sich bestimmten Themen widmet, sei es Software, sei es Hardware, also irgendwo dran rumhacken. Was dann ja reingebracht wird mit einem bestimmten Ziel, dass am Schluss das Ganze präsentiert wird. Das läuft dann so über zwei Monate. Da wirken auch sehr viele von dem Club dann selbst auch mit. Was noch gibt, sind halt Vorträge. Das ist auch hier in Berlin halt regelmäßig, dass es einmal im Monat den Vortrag hier gibt, den Club Discord ja, Quatsch, den Datengarten heißt das hier, so rum. Genau, richtig. Und das dann Vortrag zum offenen Thema ist, was dann hier live angeschaut werden kann oder auch gestreamt wird, aufgenommen wird, verbreitet wird. Das sind so einzelne Projekte oder was hier jetzt auch stattgefunden hat, um mal kurz da reinzugehen. Ich hatte jetzt zum Beispiel einen Amateurfunklehrgang gemacht hier in den Clubräumen, bietet sich an, ist halt groß, hier gibt es eine Leinwand, kann man halt einfach vorstellen, das ganze Leute halt zum Amateurfunk zu bringen, woraus sich dann auch nochmal eine komplett eigene Gruppe entwickelt hat, die sich weiterhin hier regelmäßig trifft.
Ist das generell was, wo man sagen kann, dafür sind Hackspaces auch geeignet. Ich bin jemand, der, wenn man sich durchguckt, also Hackspace irgendwie das Thema, das dazu passt, aber ich bin jemand, der gerne etwas anbieten würde. Selbst wenn ich nicht dazugehöre, gehe ich hin und frage mal, wie wär's denn, könnte ich bei euch, also so wie es Hard of Code jetzt anscheinend bis jetzt schonmal einer gemacht hat, ist das so ein Ding, was eher typisch ist auch für Hackspaces?
Ja, würde ich auch so sagen. Also wir hatten vor ein paar Monaten mal eine Anhörung im Landtag Nordrhein-Westfalen, wo es darum ging, die Politiker wollten sich mal erklären lassen, was das eigentlich mit diesen Hackerspaces auf sich hat und ob man da irgendwie das Modell der Kulturförderung drauf anwenden kann und so. Und also in Nordrhein-Westfalen ist die FDP noch im Landtag und ein Abgeordneter von der FDP meinte dann, also wenn ich sie jetzt richtig verstanden habe, betreiben sie so eine Art anarchistische Volkshochschule. Das trifft das eigentlich ganz gut. Also so neue Formen des Voneinander-Lernens werden auf jeden Fall ausprobiert und das kann halt ganz ad hoc sein, dass man einfach jemanden über die Schulter guckt, der sein Ding macht oder manche sagen halt, wir machen jetzt auch mal eine Kursreihe, wir machen eine Vortragsreihe. Das gehört auch dazu, dass man halt eine eigene Form des Lernens ausprobiert.
Jetzt hast du gesagt, der Landtag hat mal gefragt, das stelle ich mir auch spannend vor, also auch hier wieder, der ursprüngliche Ansatz ist, Individuen suchen im Prinzip eine Höhle, wo sie ungestört die Dinge tun können, die sie tun. Aber wenn das dann so eine Außenwirkung hat oder wenn Leute von Außen das mitbekommen, dann wirkt das vielleicht viel größer als organisatorische Einheit, als es vielleicht eigentlich gedacht ist. Gibt es so, gerade auch weil es in Berlin zum Beispiel so viele gibt, gibt es mittlerweile so eine Art Anspruch, der von außen immer beobachten kann, ich werde jetzt irgendwie als Entität wahrgenommen?
Ja, haben wir versucht, es war vor vier Jahren schon gewesen, da waren wir dann auch im Abgeordnetenhaus, haben dort auch mal Hackerspaces einfach mal vorgestellt, um mal reinzubringen, was ist das überhaupt, um das als Kultur für Berlin auch wahrzunehmen. Haben dort im Kultur-Aschauß auch mit dabei gesessen. Frank-Rieger und ich waren da halt drin, haben das Ganze vorgestellt. Letzten Endes ist es glaube ich irgendwie bei der SPD dort hängen geblieben, ach so, das ist also auch noch mal so ein Raum, wo sich Bands treffen können, um proben zu können. Die kennen das nicht anders hier in dieser Stadt. Das ist als Band-Proberaum, das kann man alles über den Band-Proberaum-Geldzuschuss finanzieren. Die haben es einfach nicht verstanden, leider.
Ja, aber es ist nicht so, dass dann auch Leute, was ich jetzt eigentlich mal so sagen kann, sagen, ihr seid doch so ein Hackerspace, könnt ihr nicht mal mein 3D-Klima-Lager auspucken?
Ein bisschen geht es schon weiter. Ich habe es in Köln gemerkt, mit der Dingfabrik. Das kam schon ganz anders als FabLab. Da ist dann hinter die Stadt auch mit draufgesprungen. Die haben das dann wahrgenommen und sehen das als Kultur. Teilt der Stadt auch mit an. Es kommt wirklich von Stadt zu Stadt auch drauf an, wie die Leute dort in den entsprechenden Gremien drin sitzen, ticken und verstehen, was so ein Hackerspace ist.
Kat, könnte ich mir vorstellen, ist das oder andersrum gefragt. Das hört sich jetzt so an, ihr wollt jetzt einen Hackerspace gründen, damit ihr einen Ort habt, an dem ihr mir die Dinge tun könnt, die ihr sowieso schon tut, nämlich Angebote für Frauen machen. Ist es aber gleichzeitig auch gedacht als eine Art politischer Leuchtturm, wo man genau dieses Thema, dieses Anliegen, das da besteht, nämlich Frauen in Zugang zu ermöglichen, dass es einen Kristallisationspunkt gibt, wo man sagen kann, wenn ich mich für das Thema interessiere, muss ich dahin gehen. Ist das auch Teil des Plans?
Ja, das ist natürlich auch Teil des Plans. Hauptsächlich wollten wir einfach einen Space haben, wo wir hacken können. Abnerden, aber das politische schwingt natürlich mit. Das ist ja auch ein total wichtiges Thema. Wir schaffen damit eine Sichtbarkeit für Frauen. Das ist auch ein wichtiges Anliegen und auch ein Aspekt der Hard-of-Code, den wir auf jeden Fall haben, zwecken.
Ich habe jetzt widersprüchliche Informationen in dieser Sendung bekommen. Das eine ist, dass irgendwann gesagt wurde, eigentlich in Berlin letzten Mal noch mal ein Hackspace aufzumachen. Schwierig, ist schon ganz schön voll. Gizmo hat aber gerade gesagt, mehr neue Hackspace. Das ist das Allerbeste, was uns passieren kann. Ich nehme da Mixed Signals wahr. Also sind jetzt genug in Berlin oder brauchen wir noch mehr?
Ich bin der Meinung, es kann immer gerne noch einen mehr geben. Und Hackerspaces an jeder Ecke kann auch nicht schaden in der Struktur. Ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht, dass gerade ein sehr lokaler Umkreis wichtig ist. Also dass so ein Hackspace nicht am anderen Ende der Stadt liegt. Gerade in Berlin, Finsteres, Neukölln, was jetzt für uns, für die Raumfahrt Agentur genau das andere Ende ist. Ist doch so eine schwierige Sache, wenn man da erst anreist und alle Pläne des regelmäßigen Erscheinens und umso fleißigeren Tüftelns gehen dann meistens doch irgendwie zurück, wenn das nicht doch ein bisschen ein lokales Wohnzimmer auch ist. Oder Arbeitszimmer eben.
Was heißt lokal? Ein Block oder ein Straßenzug?
Ja, was man mit dem Elektrofahrrad so in zehn Minuten schafft. Auf jeden Fall eine halbe Stunde Bahn und noch viel mehr, noch längere Wege sind ein anderes Kriterium. Das sind dann schon andere Situationen. Gerade für ihr Arbeiten und auch Freizeit.
Aber das ist schon ein bisschen widersprüchlich. Wenn man so denkt, Hackspace als Ort der Begegnung, das nimmt dann auch so ein bisschen ab. Sondern man bleibt halt irgendwie so in seinem Kies.
Ja, andererseits aber wir haben, wie gesagt, von der Fläche sind es 250 Quadratmeter und da lange nicht alles abgedeckt. Mehrfachliches ist immer möglich. Und gerade dafür müsste es dann vielleicht auch noch andere Räume geben, die in dem Bereich Maschinen oder andere technische Zugangsmöglichkeiten da sind. Also das noch ein bisschen diverser zu haben oder da auch mehr Breite zu haben, sollte kein Problem sein.
Aber für dich sozusagen wäre es durchaus wünschen wert, wenn es jetzt eine Fachrichtung gibt, die es bei euch noch nicht gibt, dass die nicht dann auch noch zu euch kommt, sondern sagt, das wäre schon auch cool, macht doch einfach euren eigenen Space.
Gerade wenn der Raum schon am Limit ist und das ist ja also was jetzt die Raumstruktur betrifft, die ist definiert, das sind die Bereiche soweit gesetzt, dann klar, man muss ja nicht immer alles noch unter einen Dach drunter.
Ich mag es ja, wenn nicht alles immer wachsen muss. Cat, wie sieht es eigentlich zu sagen, wenn es angenommen noch ein Frauen-only-Hackspace in Berlin, gute Idee oder nicht?
Ja, total gute Idee. Also von mir aus noch fünf. Also ich glaube, es gibt genug Frauen, die Bock drauf haben und dir das Angebot wahrnehmen würden.
Okay, und Pylor und Joel, mehr Hackspace gleich gute Idee immer?
Ja, mehr Diversität und auch mehr Discordianismus dazwischen. Und irgendwie hab ich das Gefühl, man kennt sich ja doch untereinander, dass man sich halt mal besuchen geht, mal schaut irgendwo, was läuft in anderen Spaces, vielleicht mal ein cooles Vortragsprogramm da gerade läuft und einfach mal vorbeischaut und irgendwie mal auch den Blick in den Tellerrand irgendwie wagen kann. Oder auch man sieht so, hey, in der Raumfahrt Agentur, die haben einfach einen geilen Laserkater da rumstehen. Eigentlich will ich das in meinem Space und in die Ecke auch, um nicht immer natürlich halbe Stadt fahren zu müssen. Und da mal so ein bisschen einfach mitzunehmen.
Ich will einen Laserkater haben, weil ich das Gefühl, das fällt ganz schön oft. Jetzt gibt es noch einen Punkt, wo ich mich frage, die so ein ganz bisschen erinnert, das ja, was erzählt, auch so eine Künstlerkollektive. Und da gab es ja auch mal das Konzept, gleich ein ganzes Künstlerhaus ist. Also nicht nur, dass das, wie heißt das, von der Stadtplanung her, ein dritter Ort ist, sondern dass man sagt, man könnte es doch eigentlich gleich größer machen. Wir haben unsere Werkstatt und oben drüber wohnen wir alle. Gibt es so eine Konzepte auch? Also dass man nicht nur sagt, wir arbeiten und feiern vielleicht zusammen, sondern tatsächlich, wir machen gleich so ein Hack-Haus? Ja, gibt's auch.
Also es gab Planungen dazu und es sind auch welche umgesetzt worden. In Essen gibt es ein Haus, was aus einem Umfeld des Unperfekthauses herausgefallen ist, die dann auch quasi im Untergeschoss Ladengeräume haben, Werkstätten, damit man das Fahrrad nicht da oben schleppen muss zum Beispiel und oben drüber auch Wohnungen haben und als Kollektiv auch wahrgenommen wird.
Und wird sich das sozusagen, also ist das was, was vielleicht noch mehr jetzt kommt oder sind das so vereinzelte Dinge, die man mal macht?
Ich hab nicht so viele erfolgreiche Sachen gesehen in dem Bereich, was erstaunlich ist, weil das wirklich schon lange diskutiert wird. Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass viele Leute dann auch sagen gut so ein Hackerspace mit dem inherenten Hackerspace-Drama will ich dann vielleicht nicht noch in meinem Privatleben haben.
Also was ich da noch fragen wollte, ist eigentlich, ist eure Erfahrung nach, ist Mailinglist ein diskutables Organisationsmittel für einen Hackerspace? Oder gibt es ja mittlerweile moderneres?
Ja, selten. Also das ist auf jeden Fall irgendwie das Grundmittel. Ist auch so ein bisschen, was wir auch in den Designpages mit aufgeschrieben haben. Also eine Mailingliste brauchst du schon. Mail kann irgendwie fast jede Person halt bearbeiten. Alles andere drüber hinaus ist ein Streitthema.
Ja, also Mailinglisten haben Probleme. Mailinglisten können total entgleisen. Irgendwann werden wir sicherlich auch was besseres als Mailinglisten haben, aber bis jetzt haben wir halt Mailinglisten. In den Designpattern haben wir gesagt, ihr braucht eine Mailingliste, um was zu diskutieren. Die Designpattern sind allerdings auch schon neun Jahre alt. Das war eine andere Zeit. Damals kannten wir auch kein Crowdfunding, das hieß damals noch Betteln. Jetzt sind wir alle ein bisschen weiter. Also damals haben wir gesagt, wir brauchen eine Mailingliste, ihr braucht einen Wiki, um Sachen aufzuschreiben, damit man die dann nachschlagen kann, also als Knowledge Base. Ihr braucht irgendwie ein Echtzeitmedium und das war damals IRC. Aus diesen drei Elementen könnt ihr euch dann eure sinnvolle Kommunikation zusammen basteln.
Ja, wir haben die Designpattern sehr nicht gelesen. Wir benutzen einfach Slack, das vereint die Funktionen alle ganz gut.
Da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es unter Hardcore-Open-Source-Leuten natürlich wieder eine riesige Diskussion darum geben kann.
Die Hardcore-Open-Source-Leute sollen bitte ein Tool bauen, das so funktioniert, wie Slack und Open Source ist. Da würde ich mich total freuen.
Falls jemand da was hat, gerne Bescheid sagen in den Kommentaren zur Sendung. Ich würde jetzt ganz zum Schluss noch mal ein bisschen nach eurem Nähkästchen fragen. Es gibt jetzt ganz viel, was wir gehört haben, wie man selber so einen Hackspace macht. Was man dafür braucht auch. Aber noch mal, wenn man jetzt auch denkt, ich würde mal rumreisen und mir vielleicht so ein paar angucken, in welche Städte lohnt es sich denn zu fahren? Oder was sind eure Lieblingshackspaces oder Geschichten, die ihr da erlebt habt oder Dinge, wo ihr sagt, okay, den muss man unbedingt mal gesehen haben. Das ist so ein Hackspace, den man auf jeden Fall nicht verpasst haben sollte. Also Berlin ist jetzt, können wir mal hier anfangen, es gibt hier die Marienstraße 11, Chaos Computer Club Berlin, da wird alle zwei Monate das Chaos Radio rausgesendet, da kann man sich den auch mal angucken. Gibt es hier auch offene Tage, wo man vorbeikommen kann, oder?
Dienstag und Donnerstag.
Dienstag und Donnerstag. Uhrzeit?
So abends ab 19.30, 20 Uhr so die Ecke rum.
Dann jetzt einmal rum vielleicht erstmal, wer noch mehr Geschichten hat, gerne auch die Hackspace, den man unbedingt gesehen haben sollte. Nicht der eigene Gizmo, nicht der eigene.
Okay, dann das Lobbo 23 in Würzburg.
Warum das?
Keinem Tipp.
Muss ja nicht immer die größten Städte sein.
War das dein erster?
Ja genau, das war historisch. Seit 2004 gibt es die da schon. Das ist da gewachsen. Ein ganz kleines Städtchen.
Ich war sehr beeindruckt in Oslo, also nicht vom BitRaf, das ist so der Hackerspace da, sondern da gibt es noch einen anderen Fabrikan, Fabrikan oder so heißt das. Das ist einfach ein wahnsinniger Makerspace. Das ist in einer riesigen Halle. Also die können in dieser Halle Hausboote bauen, so groß ist die und die haben halt total viele verschiedene Ecken. Die haben so eine riesige Textil-Ecke und die haben zwei so fette, krasse, dreimal zwei Meter Fräsen. Und die haben ganz viel Woodworking, also Holzkram. Und die haben so einen Roboterarm aus den 90ern und versuchen da gerade irgendwie eine Mischung aus 3D-Drucker und Fräse an diesen Roboterarm ranzubauen. Und die machen, also die sind richtig krasse Erfinder und die machen so geilen Scheiß. Und das war wirklich ziemlich beeindruckend. Das war glaube ich der coolste Space, in dem ich hier war.
Kannst du jemanden, der eh da war oder wie kommt man an sowas ran und rein?
Ja, der Typ, der das gegründet hat, da bin ich auch hier über den CTC quasi, über irgendwie so Hacker-Dings. Ich war in Oslo irgendwie und ich hatte keinen Bock im Hotel zu schlafen. Und dann habe ich einfach bei Freunden von Freunden geschlafen. Das war halt der Typ, der das gemacht hat. Und das war ein sehr schönes Wochenende.
Bester Hacker-Space aller Zeiten?
Wenn ich irgendwo hinfahre, dann besuche ich immer gerne Hacker-Spaces dort. Also in Helsinki war ich neulich und habe dort ein Hacker-Space gesehen. Total nett und kuschig und klein. Ich glaube, der, der mich am meisten beeindruckt hat, außer den erwähnten amerikanischen Spaces, NYC Resista in New York und Neuss Bridge in San Francisco, die muss man auch mal gesehen haben. Total toll. Ja, MetaLab in Wien ist auch auf jeden Fall irgendwie ganz, ganz wichtig zu erleben. Der mich am meisten beeindruckt hat, das war der Hacker-Space Singapur. Da war ich eingeladen worden von Umwege. Jemand, der auch auf dem CCC schon gesprochen hat, Joe Ito, hatte da was organisiert mit der Regierung von Singapur zusammen. Und da sollte ich dann was über Hackerspaces erzählen. Hab ich dann auch gemacht und hab denen auch was über Clubmarte erzählt. War nicht einfach rüber zu bringen. Dann wurde ich dann halt in diesen Hackerspace in Singapur eingeladen. Es war halt Dezember, es war 40 Grad draußen, richtig heiß. Und die hatten halt in dieser Stadt, die halt sowieso schon sehr interessant ist, also halt dieses Disneyland-Methode-Strafe, hat William Gibson das mal genannt, ganz interessante Kultur mit auf die Straße spucken, gibt vielleicht so und so viel Stockhiebe und so weiter. Da hatten sie sich dann so ihr anarchistisches Hackerspace-Refugium gebaut, wo sie halt auch irgendwie Schilder aufgestellt haben mit, wer pups zahlt so und so viel Singapur-Dollar und so. Und natürlich war das alles komplett anders. Also es ist halt irgendwie Asien und das ist halt in dem Viertel, was arabisch geprägt ist in Singapur. Und exotischer geht's nicht. Und ich hab die Tür aufgemacht und das war genauso wie zu Hause. Also es war, da waren halt meine Leute da. Und das Einzige, was vielleicht noch irgendwie anders war, dass die halt aus dem Hackerspace Singapur mich dann gefragt haben, und du bist aus dem Hackerspace in Deutschland.
Pilar? Ja, es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, wenn man unterwegs ist, mal Urlaub gemacht und irgendwie mal so nach einer Woche rumreisen und irgendwelche Landschaft anguckt, mal wieder ein bisschen Kultur, also die Hackkultur erleben möchte. Mal einen Blick auf die Hackerspace-Karte zu werfen und zu schauen, ist irgendwie in meiner Gegend mal so ein Hackerspace. Ich hab das da mal vor ein paar Jahren gemacht, dass ich in New York in Nordendland unterwegs war. Und die hatten zufährweise Club-Abend an dem Abend, wo ich dann in der Stadt war, bin einfach mal vorbei gegangen. Das war irgendwie so typisch britisches Clubhaus. Das heißt, sie haben da so Häuser, wo sich mehrere Gruppen drin treffen. Man zahlt dann irgendwie so seine Zweifel und Eintritt und darf dann auch noch hinter an die Theke gehen. Die hatten dann so einen Raum hinten, wo sich dann dieser lokale Hackerspace getroffen hatte. Die dann auch irgendwie in den Schrank kamen, wo sie Zeugs einlagern können. Die treffen sich einmal die Woche halt dort. Irgendwie waren da gerade ein paar Leute einfach da gewesen, die dann einen alten Amiga auseinandergeschraubt haben. Da dachten wir so, ja, hier bist du schon irgendwie richtig. Es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall tatsächlich mal, in irgendwelche Räume reinzuschauen. Welcher Space mich jetzt vor Kurzem echt fasziniert hatte, wo ich vor einem Monat, Anfang des Monats war, in Augsburg gewesen, die sich vor ein, zwei Jahren da einen recht großen Space geleistet haben. Der ist auch komplett ausgestattet mit den ganzen Maschinenzeugen und mit Türöffnungsanlage, sonst wie auch immer. Das war echt faszinierend, diesen Raum zu sehen, wie die sich eingerichtet haben, weil er relativ frisch war, mit modernen Sachen, indirekte LED-Beleuchtung und so ein Kram, und gucken, dass man wenig Energie verbraucht. Da schon sehr viel Hackvalue reingesetzt haben.
Jetzt, weil Cat gerade gesagt hatte, Roboter-Arm mit 3D-Drucker und Frise dran. Krasseste Erfindung in einem Hackspace, die ich jemals gesehen hab? Oder krassestes Ding? Na, da werden die Köpfe bedächtig gewegt.
Ich hab ziemlich krasse Dinge gesehen, die im Umfeld des MetaLabs gebaut worden sind für das jährlich stattfindende Festival für Cocktail-Robotik. Also wo Roboter gebaut werden, die Cocktails mixen, ausschenken etc. Und da gab es, beeindruckend war zum Beispiel, eine Maschine, die auf Basis von einer Betonmischmaschine Wodka und Orangensaft vermischt hat.
Für die größeren Hackerspaces, okay.
Überall. Ich fand's auch mal krass, wo dann irgendwann in Köln in einer Dingfabrik gesagt wurde, ja wir haben da irgendwie mal so einen Industrieroboter erhalten. Wir müssen unsere Halle auflösen, wollt ihr den haben? Und formen dann irgendwie mit so einem tonnenschweren Industrieroboter an für 6-Achsen-Verfahren und so. Können wir den hier irgendwo abstellen?
Und jetzt möchte ich ganz zum Schluss noch etwas für die wirklich Anfänger fragen. Also jemand, der vielleicht diesen Podcast runtergeladen hat und dann so denkt, Mensch, ich würde da wirklich gerne mal hin und wieder das angucken. Jetzt ist es ja so, dass so ein Hackspace, wenn man da als Fremder an so einem offenen Tag reinkommt, also irgendwie Ehrfrucht gebieten, da sitzen halt Leute und frickeln halt alle an irgendwas und sind auch mit sich beschäftigt. Und es gibt ja sozusagen keinen Türsteher oder irgendwas. Was ist denn der beste Weg als Neuling, um in einem Hackspace sozusagen, um den kennenzulernen? Also als wirklich jemand, der gar keine Ahnung hat, also der nicht aus dem CCC in ein Umfeld kommt, der wirklich denkt, ich finde diese ganzen Themen spannend, aber ich hatte noch nie damit zu tun, ich möchte das jetzt mal machen.
Ja, also der offene Tag ist natürlich schon ganz praktisch dafür. Die meisten Hackspaces haben mittlerweile auch das Bewusstsein dafür, dass dort dann neue Leute aufschlagen könnten und meist dann irgendwie ein, zwei Personen quasi abgesetzt, um neue Leute halt zu empfangen. Was praktisch sind natürlich Spaces, wo eine Bar ist. Da kann man dann einfach mal irgendwie hingehen, sich eine Mate holen und dort dann mit dem Barroboter halt ins Gespräch reinkommen und einfach mal ein bisschen Gespräche führen.
Ich mache ein komisches Bild in meinem Kopf, aber gut. Mit dem Barroboter sprechen. Na gut.
Ich glaube, das Beste ist halt, wenn man selber begeistert ist und ein Projekt hat und das dann halt auch vorstellt. Also alle sind da, weil sie von irgendwas begeistert sind. Das kann Industrieroboter sein, das können Brettspiele sein. Wichtig ist nur, du brennst für eine Sache und möchtest diese Begeisterung mit der Welt teilen. Das ist schon mal ein guter Einstieg in Hackerspace.
Aber aufpassen, das sind Nerds. Wenn du da zu stark und zu schnell mit viel Intuismus reingehst, dann ist das auch nicht immer so fördernd.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Na ja, wenn du jetzt in so ein Space reinkommst und sagst, hey, guck mal, ich hab ein cooles Projekt mitgebracht, kann ich das mal hier vorstellen? Und jetzt nimmt man meine ganze Aufwechslung auf mich und so weiter. Ich glaube, das klappt auch nicht so immer. Am besten mal langsam ins Gespräch reinkommen, mal eine Maht holen und dann weiter klauen. Immer. Bis der Schlesien Design Patterns drin.
Kloputzen auch. Und Vereinsgründung. Vielen Dank, Pylon, für's Einblick geben. Und Kat, die noch mal sagen wird, wie es jetzt weitergeht mit dem neuen Hackerspace, den es noch gar nicht gibt.
Ja, also wir sind jetzt ja erstmal jeden Donnerstag im X-Hain, in Friedrichshain, in der Grünberger Straße. 14 ist das. Und wer sich irgendwie als Frau identifiziert und da mal vorbeikommen möchte, ist sehr herzlich eingeladen. Wir sind auch sehr freundlich. Und ansonsten kann man sich irgendwie informieren, wie es genau bei uns weitergeht auf unserer Twitter-Seite und auf unserer Homepage, die heißt heartofcode.org. Also kann man finden. Und da gibt es auch einen Blog und es gibt auch ein E-Mail-Newsletter. Der E-Mail-Newsletter wird dann einfach in einem Blog gepostet hinterher. Also wenn man irgendwie zu faul ist, sein E-Mail zu lesen, kann man es auch da immer nachlesen, was passiert, ein bisschen Zeit verzögert, wenn wir Zeit haben, es mal einzuflicken. Also so kann man sich informieren, wie es weitergeht. Wir haben auch einen Kalender. Wir haben extrem viele Events jetzt in nächster Zeit. Wir sind auf der Republika, einige von uns geben da Talks. Wir haben einen Stand, wir haben ein Meetup. Wir sind auf einem Tech-Summit mit einem Stand, ein Meetup und ein Talk.
Kommt nicht an euch vorbei.
Genau, wir haben diverse Workshops, wir verkaufen wie gesagt Schnaps, vielleicht gegen Spende am 1. Mai in Kreuzberg, da kann man uns finden.
Und auch vielen Dank an Gizmo von der Raumfahrtagentur. Sehr schön. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, falls ihr noch einen Hackerspace habt, wo ihr denkt, den müsste man unbedingt erwähnen oder zumindest gesehen haben, schreibt uns gerne in die Kommentare. Mein Name ist Markus Richter, ich bedanke mich nochmal bei allen meinen Gästen und dem Publikum. Und ich kann noch eine Sache sagen, bevor ich gehe, lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön. Eure Backups. Tschüss!